hagamos otro problema de la sección de
distribución normal del libro
estadística de secado ce punto org de ap
y lo estoy usando porque es un libro de
libre distribución y este hecho un buen
libro los problemas que presentan son yo
creo una buena práctica para nosotros
veamos número tres de hecho puedes ir al
sitio web y descargar el libro supón que
el peso promedio de niñas de un año en
eeuu se distribuye normalmente con una
media de 9.5 gramos y aquí debe de ser
kilogramos tengo un hijo de 10 meses y
pesa aproximadamente 20 libras que es
como 9 kilogramos no 9.5 gramos 9.5
gramos es nada
ese día el peso de un ratón o algo así
esto tiene que estar en kilogramos de
cualquier manera con una desviación
estándar de aproximadamente 1.1 gramos
entonces la media es igual a 9.5
kilogramos estoy suponiendo y la
desviación estándar es igual a 1.1 sin
usar una calculadora
esa es una clave interesante estima el
porcentaje de
de un año en los eeuu que cumplen con
las siguientes condiciones cuando nos
dicen sin usar calculadora nos están
dando la clave de que en este problema
vamos a usar lo que se llama la regla
empírica la regla empírica o también
llamada la regla del 68 95 99.7 y si te
acuerdas del nombre esencialmente te
acuerdas de la regla si tenemos una
distribución normal y aquí voy a hacer
una breve revisión antes de resolver el
problema si tenemos una distribución
normal y aquí va a ser mi gráfica mi
gráfica de campana no me salió muy bien
pero te das una idea es una gráfica
simétrica
aquí tenemos la media y si tomamos una
desviación estándar arriba de la media y
una desviación estándar abajo de la
media entonces aquí tenemos la media más
una desviación estándar y aquí la media
menos una desviación estándar si tenemos
una distribución normal perfecta la poli
ha encontrado un valor que esté entre la
media menos una desviación estándar y la
media más una desviación estándar
eso sería esta área que estoy sombreando
ese valor sería puedes imaginar los 68
68 % 88 por ciento de probabilidad de
que vas a obtener un valor en un rango
de una desviación estándar con respecto
a la media una desviación estándar
arriba de la media o una desviación
estándar abajo de la media o en el ínter
ahora con dos desviaciones estándar si
vamos una desviación estándar en esa
dirección y una desviación estándar en
esta otra dirección si nos preguntamos
entonces escuela pública encontrará un
valor dentro de dos desviaciones
estándar también puedes adivinar lo es
igual al 95% y eso incluye esta zona
central por lo que el 68% esta incluye
95% me parece que ya sabes entonces por
dónde va la cosa
si ahora tomamos tres desviaciones abajo
de la media y tres desviaciones arriba
de la media
la regla empírica o la regla del 68 95
99.7 nos dice que hay una probabilidad
del 99.7 por ciento para una
distribución normal de encontrar un
resultado que se ubique dentro de tres
desviaciones estándar alrededor de la
media es decir arriba de tres
desviaciones abajo de la media y abajo
de tres desviaciones arriba de la media
eso es lo que la regla empírica nos
plantea
veamos si lo podemos aplicar en este
problema así que nos dan la media y la
desviación estándar déjame dibujar esto
voy a dibujar mi eje lo mejor que pueda
ese es mi eje ahora voy a dibujar una
curva de campana déjame dibujar mi culpa
de campana no está mal para una curva de
campana hecha a mano esta curva es
simétrica esta altura aquí es la misma
que hay del otro lado
tienes la idea no soy una computadora
entonces la media aquí ponemos la media
que es igual a 9.5 no va a poner las
unidades está en kilogramos si tomamos
una desviación estándar arriba de este
valor sabemos que la desviación estándar
es 1.1 por lo que a sumar la a 9.5
obtenemos 10.6 deja de poner una línea
punteada arriba de este valor ahora si
vamos una desviación estándar abajo de
la media si restamos 1.1 de 9.5 vamos a
obtener 8.48 punto 4 si sumamos dos
desviaciones estándar arriba de la media
esto va a ser aquí tenemos una
desviación estándar aquí otra desviación
estándar tendremos 11.7 si ahora
queremos tres desviaciones estándar
arriba de la media agregamos 1.1 para
obtener 12.8 vamos al otro lado una
desviación estándar abajo de la media es
8.42 desviaciones estándar abajo
restamos 1
1 para obtener 7.33 desviaciones
estándar abajo de la media restamos
nuevamente un 1.1 para obtener 6.2
kilogramos es el preámbulo para nuestro
problema cuál es la probabilidad de
encontrar una niña en eeuu cuyo peso sea
menor de 8.4 kilogramos aunque
deberíamos decir cuya masa es menor que
8.4 kilogramos entonces si vemos aquí
abajo la posibilidad de encontrar un
bebé una bebé de menos de un año de edad
cuyo amasa es menor 8.4 kilogramos es
esta área y digo más a por qué
kilogramos es unidad de masa aunque
mucha gente la usa comunidad de peso
pero bueno es esta área aquí y cómo
podemos calcular esta área bajo la curva
normal usando la regla empírica sabemos
el valor de esta área sabemos el valor
de ésta de aquí que es la que está entre
menos una desviación estándar y más una
desviación estándar alrededor de la
media la cual es 68% lo cual quiere
decir que lo que está fuera de esta
región debajo de la curva normal es 32%
pues sabemos que debajo en la curva
normal
al cien por cien por ciento o uno
dependiendo de cómo lo quieras ver pues
como tú sabes si tenemos la suma de
todas las posibilidades combinadas esto
tiene que sumar 1 o 100%
ahora si tú sumas esta porción con esta
porción a sumar estas dos porciones
tiene que ser el remanente que es 100
menos 38% es 32% si tú sumas esta
porción con esta porción de acá te tiene
que dar 32 por ciento pues hay una
normalidad perfecta no están diciendo
que hay distribución normal entonces hay
una simetría perfecta entonces este lado
y este lado tiene que ser exactamente
iguales hay simetría son exactamente
iguales lo cual quiere decir que esta
zona de aquí deja de ponerlo en rosa
parece más bien morado esta zona aquí
mide 16 por ciento y estará aquí mide
también 16 por ciento entonces la
probable a obtener un valor mayor a una
desviación estándar arriba de la media
es esta zona en la derecha que es igual
a 16 por ciento y la probable a obtener
un resultado que sea menor a una
desviación estándar por debajo de la
media es igual a esta zona de aquí 16
por ciento entonces nos tienen la
probabilidad de tener una bebé cuyo peso
es menor a 8.4 kilogramos menos de 8.4
kilogramos es esta zona de aquí que es
16 por ciento 16 por ciento
este es el inciso a hagamos el inciso b
entre 7.3 kilogramos y 11.7 kilogramos
7.3 kilogramos aquí lo tenemos se ubica
dos desviaciones abajo de la media
mientras que 11.7 kilogramos se ubica a
una a dos desviaciones arriba de la
media esencialmente nos están
preguntando cuál es la probabilidad
tiene un resultado que esté a dos
desviaciones estándar de la media aquí
tenemos la media en el centro aquí
tenemos dos desviaciones abajo de la
media y aquí tenemos dos desviaciones
arriba de la media y esto no lo da
directamente la regla empírica dentro de
dos desviaciones estándar con respecto a
la media tienes una probabilidad del 95%
de obtener un resultado que se encuentre
en ese rango de dos desviaciones
estándar con respecto a la media
finalmente inciso c la problema de tener
una bebé de un año en los eeuu cuyo peso
sea mayor
de 12.8 kilogramos el valor de 12.8 se
encuentra a tres desviaciones estándar
por arriba de la media entonces queremos
saber la probable a obtener un valor que
esté más allá de tres desviaciones
estándar por arriba de la media lo cual
corresponde a esta área aquí no va a ser
con otro color para que resalte es esta
área aquí esta gran cola hacia este lado
queremos averiguar ese valor de
probabilidad regresemos a la regla
empírica por la regla empírica sabemos
cuál es el valor de probabilidad entre
menos tres desviaciones estándar y más
tres desviaciones estándar sabemos que
toda esta región y puede iluminar la
completamente es el último inciso ya no
importa sabemos que toda ésta
tiene una pluralidad de 99.7 es casi
toda la probabilidad está comprendida en
esta región entonces que nos queda para
esas colas aquí tenemos una de estas
colas y aquí tenemos por abajo de tres
desviaciones estándar de la media la
otra de esas colas entonces para menos
de tres desviaciones estándar por debajo
de la media y más de tres desviaciones
estándar por arriba de la media tomadas
en conjunto tienen que ser igual al
remanente tan solo punto 3 por ciento
para el remanente ahora estas dos áreas
tienen que ser iguales son simétricas
entonces este es igual a punto 3 entre
2.15 por ciento y esta también es igual
a punto 15% entonces la probabilidad de
tener una bebé de un año de edad en los
eeuu que pese más de 12.8 kilogramos
suponiendo una distribución normal
perfecta es el área bajo la curva que se
encuentra más allá de tres desviaciones
estándar con respecto a la media y esa
área es
esa probabilidad es de punto 15% punto
15% en fin espero que esto te haya sido
útil